yeah so I'm Dan Wilson here to talk
about the web animations API we're gonna
talk about general web animation as well
but kind of geared towards how web
animation works in 2019 according to
browsers and specs and kind of what's
provided by default from a from the
browsers these days yeah you know
animation is not a new concept and it's
not even a new concept on the web by any
means we've been doing this for four
years at this point and all the way from
things like just doing a set timeout or
a set interval and changing the position
of something on a screen jQuery animate
where I think a lot of people first were
introduced to animation where you
provide kind of a starting point and
where you want it to go and the browser
or the library jQuery would take care of
the in-betweens requestanimationframe
which kind of improved what you get out
of set interval by giving being smarter
about it and being more efficient
there's canvas elements that you can
actually draw upon and clear out and do
a lot of things in their WebGL and you
know in a related way building on a lot
of graphics technology there's CSS the
one of I guess the reason that I'm even
here talking about this kind of stuff is
because of what CSS provided you know
starting 12 years ago where we were the
doors are kind of opened up on taking a
starting state and in state and doing
some interesting things in between and
letting the browser do the brunt of the
work and if that's what that's what we
got with CSS in the declarative way and
SVG animation where again we're kind of
inside of a Dom but we're able to
animate these illustrations and all of
these kind of things that help us with
telling stories and and there's a lot of
ways to do that as well
and then there's finally libraries that
build on whatever foundations that
browsers provide like green sock G SAP
is a popular one there's anime of allow
the velocity of
not a billion that would be hyperbole
but there's a lot of them and and they
make it easier for people to get in
there and work with them but you're
including libraries you're adding weight
to your pages and there's there's
limitations if you don't have a solid
foundation from the browser
you know these libraries can't innovate
as much as they could without that nice
solid foundation so lots of options what
we're gonna be focusing on today are
ones that are tied to HTML elements or
SVG elements things that are tied to
what you get in the Dom so you've got a
paragraph of text or you've got a title
or an image and moving it affecting it
in some way that it's animating on a
screen kind of focusing on the ways that
we do that today and the ways that we're
going to be able to do that in the
future so there's a new specification
and when I say new it's obviously not
new it's been evolving since about 2013
but it's at a point where it's actually
been implemented by the majority of
browsers it's it's unifying the way that
SVG animation works their smile it's
taking what CSS animation is provided
and it's taking the strengths of
JavaScript where you've got word dynamic
options and trying to unite all of them
with the same underlying engine so if
you've got something that works well in
CSS today with the help of the way of
animation spec and the web animations
API that's now being exposed whether
you're working in SVG or CSS or
JavaScript and so this is very exciting
as you all I know y'all are just
unwrapped in like this is this is
wonderful yet another thing to add to
our plate but the difference here is
that this really is not a new thing it's
taking what works across the board and
uniting them CSS is the thing that gave
us off main thread and compositor layer
efficiencies so
you know the terms like
hardware-accelerated have come out of
this well you know that's technically
iffy the fact that it's working off the
main thread it's not being affected by
the way that your page is working it's
not being affected by JavaScript that's
slowing things up it it's able to work
on its own layer and that was kind of
the key benefit that CSS gave us but
javascript gives us dynamic values CSS
does too now with custom properties but
let's just say you know you you have a
lot of flexibility with a programming
language like JavaScript to to to make a
lot of randomized dynamic animations and
for the first time now something that
CSS animation didn't give us out of the
box our actual controls to seek inside
of an animation to jump to a certain
point in animation to restart it quickly
and in a concept of a timeline which is
something that green sock and other
libraries leaned on heavily and if you
did flash work in the back in the day
like these concept of timelines keeping
everything in sync and being able to
move along that timeline or one
animation or multiple animations is kind
of integral for making everything look
right and be in sync so got a lot of
this and we got callbacks so event
listeners that you can join for kind of
when an animation finishes when it's
cancelled when it well it's really those
two but CSS also has as that as well so
it you can see how different things that
worked well in one thing is now coming
to CSS things that work well in CSS
going through KS SPG is kind of like the
next thing like they were focusing more
on getting CSS and JavaScript across the
board but we'll see that some of the
things that SVG has worked well over the
years is coming in flow so I forgot to
say at the beginning that we're not
really talking about the why to animate
today there's lots of things you can get
into cycle
cool benefits and other reasons why you
might want to animate but today at this
developer conference we're going to be
focusing on the the how and the what
there's lots of resources that and you
could fill more than enough in one talk
or a conference a full of talks of why
to animate so just for today we're gonna
do some code we're going to look at
examples and we're going to see things
move on the screen so things moving on
the screen is something that it's not a
good thing for you that is that is
something that we are going to be doing
today just as an FYI so I mentioned that
compositor layer whenever you have
elements on a page they get laid out
they go through repaint they go through
reflow as you adjust things but if it's
on promoted to this compositor layer it
kind of effectively sits above your
document so the concept is kind of like
traditional cell animation where you
know in a Bugs Bunny cartoon they've got
a fixed background and they don't
reanimate that they don't draw that
background all the time they just draw
the character that's gonna be moving and
they layer on a transparency and they
draw on that cell to to do the thing
that's animating it's the same concept
it's a similar concept with web
animation where you actually promote an
item up to a layer so a transform or an
opacity is something that can exist in
this layer without affecting everything
around it if you scale something up with
a transform to be twice as big as it was
it doesn't affect everything around it
it gets to live in its own space and
that's beneficial when we want to get
things that work fast and and without a
lot of stuttering so before we dig into
kind of what's going in here I'm not
sure how many people are familiar with
CSS animation maybe we'll do one of
those show of hand things if people are
familiar with kind of how CSS animation
works okay so
decent amount but and then there's
you'll probably see a lot of parallels
as we start talking about JavaScript
today to what you might be familiar with
CSS hopefully you'll see some things
that are new as well then you you may
not know exists
well well today we'll talk about
especially this unifying platform with
the JavaScript API that it's actually
available today with the foundational
kind of core support in Firefox in
chrome in Opera anything that blink
based like Chrome and opera safari is
very close and that it's been very close
for a while it's in tech preview it's
behind a flag if you go into your iPhone
or on on a Mac you can actually enable
it but it's off by default it will be
one day promoted to full thing but it's
not sure when and edge it's not an edge
but edge is gonna be blink soon so it'll
be there soon as well meaning like this
is actually a time where we can talk
about this in actual use not just
hypothetical and let's let's explore it
it's we've kind of gone past that let's
let's learn about it let's explore let's
see what's possible let's let's actually
build things with it
and I I will be posting these links
later or the slides later and there's
links to articles along the way you know
the thing that Chrome and Firefox both
did and presumably Safari as well is
that it's the same underlying engine
whether you decide to animate through
CSS or through JavaScript they all get
treated the same behind the scenes it's
all using the same underlying logic and
technology there's a polyfill available
as well if you can't wait for Safari
it's probably not your best option
because it hasn't been updated in a
while so but it's out there just yes so
I said that we would be talking about
the what and the how so we'll get into a
little bit of the what in the how this
is JavaScript
and I can get an element and all
elements now have a function that you
can call on it called animate it takes
two properties two parameters what you
want to animate it from or like what
your frames are gonna be so your your
states and then the second are your
timing options of how long it should be
how many times you want it to run do you
want it to go always forward or do you
want it to reverse and alternate do you
want it to stay at that state when it
ends that's what Phil does or you know
both ways do you want it to have a delay
before it starts do you want it to have
an end delay before it starts that's
something that's new to JavaScript and
not in CSS at the moment and in a
different easing which in CSS world is a
timing function how it moves according
to time and so using this code right
here I can make this animation of this
dot so we're already getting into the
visual stuff so it's exciting but it's
not just a start start state in an in
state you actually can specify the
intermediary things as well so this is
one where it's more of a pulse and it
does different things you can do
multiple properties in a in a given
animation I can affect my transform and
I can affect my opacity and I can affect
it at different times so I can say that
I want this frame to happen at zero
meaning at the start or one meaning the
end and anywhere in between going on and
of course can set any of my other timing
options as an object with duration in
milliseconds iterations Direction film
so if we take a look at this where we've
got transforms and opacities different
keyframes and timing options and if you
are familiar with CSS or if you're not
I'm gonna show you what it looks like
because it's actually very familiar to
how we would describe a CSS animation
we've got
keyframes at the same kind of intervals
same properties going on and then
setting an animation and CSS with a
timing and easing delays iterations and
the other properties so you might be
wondering with all of this you know if
we've already got one way to do it why
are we even talking about this at all I
want to talk JavaScript let's let's dig
into some real JavaScript stuff and not
the CSS stuff well I mean CSS is great
CSS has been doing a lot of cool things
in here and now we're letting us do it
in a new way so javascript didn't have
an efficient way to do animation
natively from the browser where the
browser takes on and does all the
calculations for you now it does so we
get the benefits of CSS like that
compositor layer but we also get what
JavaScript does best you know we have
access to variables it's not just a
declarative and CSS anymore it's you can
get finer control you can really
manipulate the timing and everything and
those player controls that I alluded to
earlier and so let's talk about some of
those options that you can perform on
any animation once you have it so let's
say that you did something similar as
before where you got that element
animate and you can call a place date on
it and you can see if it's running or
not you can see if it's paused or if
it's idle or if it finished and you also
have methods that you can call to change
that state so if you want to pause it we
call pause and then run that check the
animation dot play state and you'll get
back a string saying that it's paused so
already you've got some some tokens
there that you can affect other parts of
your website or application based on
these states and so here's one example
kind of a thingy walking with some
circles and you know so I can pause the
head animation or pause the left
and and I can unpause and then you know
it'll play back again so we're easing it
to it just some some some basic commands
that you get access to there's a
timeline that I mentioned there's this
property called current time that is
read and write so if you want to see how
far along in your animation you are at
any given point you can call animation
current time or you can set it so if you
set it to 200 then you can jump to the
200 millisecond point in the animation
so you know you one example of what you
can do with that is you've got these two
animations down here that are not in
sync and I can press this button capture
the current time of the first one set
the current time of the second one and
all of a sudden they are now in sync
without affecting that initial animation
so randomize it again and then sync them
together and you know these are basic
examples but there we're laying a
foundation of options that we have that
we can build up to some more impressive
kind of technologies or options as we
deal with animation and there's lots of
considerations about current time it's
the max value is kind of the delay plus
the duration times the iterations plus
the end delay if you've specified one
we've also got the concept of a playback
rate so it's no longer just I want this
animation to run 700 milliseconds I can
say I wanted to run 700 milliseconds but
I want it to run twice as fast so I can
set playback rate equals two and it'll
go twice as fast I can set it's 0.25 and
it'll go 1/4 of the speed so over here
I've got these buttons over here that's
effectively will make everything go
twice as fast so on that left hand it's
now going twice as fast as the right
hand now they're both going
twice as fast as everything else and
when it's paused here on the head I can
change and seek so that's showing the
options with the current time on this
slider where I can jump around in the
animation while it's paused so another
example of a playback rate this one's
gonna spin just FYI something in here
and I don't know what this is gonna look
like with the frame rate on projector
but it starts at a playback rate of zero
and I can increase that playback rate
ever so slowly and all of a sudden we've
got something that is an optical
illusion where like actually it looks
like I've got four circles in there and
then of course I can just slow that down
and and the playback rate is gives us a
lot of power actually to modify this
I've used that in games and act I'll
show another example in a second where
as the game progresses you can imagine
maybe something happens a little faster
it's a puzzle game and blocks fall a
little faster and Tetris or something
like that you can keep all your
animations the same you just affect the
playback rate and slowly increase it as
the difficulty increases events so we
have events in CSS as well where you can
actually do do something inside of
JavaScript to win on an add an event
listener for an animation end or an
animation cancel or a transition end or
an animation start we've got the same
kind of concept here in JavaScript where
we've got a non finish in a non canceled
there's also promises that are coming
but the callbacks are the the ones that
are implemented right now across the
board and so one of the key things that
we get here is that we can sequence our
animations together so
let's go over here let's refresh this I
know we're in Oklahoma but if you're any
know anything about Texas you'll know
that we got here so this is a sing-along
thing I don't know the red is showing up
of the state of Texas there each arc is
its own animation and because we're
inside of JavaScript on that animation
end of that arc from the two stars we
check the current position of stars we
check the current position of at we say
that we want to animate on the end of
the stars animation we start a new
animation that goes from stars to ad and
does that same thing so since we know
where all the positions are of all of
these things it's just a constant
animation a few dozen animations that
connect there so that's one of the
things that you get with green sock are
the ability to link animations together
and now we're getting some more of that
by default out of the browser actually
let's go ahead and this game so there's
a game that I played I don't know a long
time ago on the Commodore 64
that was about letters falling and you
pressed keys on the keyboard and if you
press the right key before it fell to
the ground you've got a point and if it
reached the ground you didn't do well I
don't remember the specifics but you
know in trying to recreate this you can
imagine here we've got animations of
random characters going from top to
bottom and if I type in the letters I
basically cancel the animation with
through an event and on my cancel
callback I increase my score on the
bottom right which you may or may not be
able to see but if I let the animation
go all the way to the bottom and finish
in the bottom left my lives I slowly
lose them and so I've got four three two
one and so these are just animations
that are
falling and by the time I've lost six or
seven lives I've made a game so this is
a game that uses animation that just
kicks off every once in a while it
increases as you play so by the time you
get to like a hundred points they're
gonna be like just flooding the screen
and that's just through the basics of
the web animations API with playback
rate setting in animation and latching
on to cancel events and finish events
and so as I was saying this is like
building these are building blocks and
with with a lot of the things that we
just talked about we can also increase
the options we have for interacting with
animation so you can build like a
timeline scrubber where again kind of in
that flash world where you've got a
visual representation of what's
happening in your animation you can play
through it through scrubbing so I can
here's five different elements that are
five different things that are five
different animations and they tie
together and as I move this timeline I
can see the animation go through and
then play back so it's not just one
animation timeline that I'm concerned
about it's five and I can tie them all
together because of the way that the
animations are structured okay so that's
a large part of what's available today
and so the obvious question is like well
what are the caches the native browser
support is as we said is still not 100%
but nothing really is ever a percent at
least not for some time there are some
minor inconsistencies with CSS you can't
do the same way that you style at
keyframe you can't use the same
properties and keyframes you can say
zero percent and a hundred percent for
the same set of rules
here you have to be you have to
duplicate them so there's some minor
differences there and and the biggest
thing in my mind is that there's still a
lot that's coming and the more exciting
stuff is coming like this kind of gets
us on the same page as CSS gives us a
little bit of extra power but some of
the more fun stuff is is coming what
else is coming let's go ahead and just
take a look at the future slash it's
actually now but it's just not as it's
more in the nightly and the canary and
the other dev browsers so this concept
of getting all the animations what we
did earlier is I took an animation I
saved it to a variable and then I
started performing actions on that on
that on that element and that my
variable that represented my element
that I was animating but if I don't
actually store that to a variable
currently there's no way to act on it
but in nineteen Canary versions in
chrome and all the other browsers that
have this and it's in Safari as well
there's a concept of get all animation
so you can call document get all
animations or get animations and you can
act on them so here's here's one where
we've got 250 animations powered by the
web animations API fairly smooth
considering it's that many animations
but I didn't save any of them off but I
can say pause all call document get
animations iterate through them all
pause them
and similarly play them back so again
kind of a little thing but it's it's
it's a nice thing that's gonna be
available to us motion path this was the
one that this was the one that got me
into the web animations API in the first
place is the concept that I could
actually instead of just move something
from here to here in a straight line the
the promise of CSS motion path where I
can just have a path has defined an SVG
or something and animate along that path
in practice it's not been as useful
is kind of perceived you're very limited
to pixels you can't kind of make it
responsive the the path that you've got
currently but it is in Chrome it's also
in Firefox nightly now and this gives us
options like this so I've got it's a
blue element at the top of the screen
that's gonna come back down and for
visualization I've also got the path
drawing but when we're talking about
motion path the path isn't going to
actually be there it's just this little
blue item is following the path I give
it the vector definition of that path as
you might find in SVG and tell it to go
from 0% to 100% of that path I can
change the path as it goes along to so
with that it just keeps going so this is
what's really happening there is that
path is going and if we look at the this
is actually using a CSS animation but
again it's the same thing here so the MN
animation is just saying take it from
offset is it distance 0 to 100% and the
browser does everything else this is one
of those key areas where SVG was really
strong in this and now we can do with
any arbitrary element or we can do it
inside of our SPG's through CSS or
through the web animations API in
JavaScript and then one of the things
that I'm really excited about is the
concept of composite timing option so
lots of CSS properties take multiple
values like transform transform you can
call scale translate rotate lots of
other options and you can also do a list
of them so you can say scale and rotate
and then if you try and do a second
animation on that or some other state
it's gonna override it because it's CSS
and you set a new value it's just gonna
overwrite what was there but with the
composite property it's actually saying
okay I started with a scale in a rotate
and then when I say I want to do an
animation of a different scale I'm just
going to add that on to the existing
list
this is in firefox nightly Chrome Canary
Safari check preview it hasn't landed in
the the true brow or the the non dev
browsers yet and this is also one of
those things where this is coming to the
web animations API first meaning the
JavaScript portion but there's also talk
about getting it into CSS you know one
of the options they were saying is kind
of like we have exclamation point
important and yes I we could also have
that same concept but add or some other
composite option and so this one is
probably easier to see in action as well
let's refresh that page and see Clippers
okay so I've got a star nothing
happening on it and then I have this
button that says add random
transformation so there's going to do an
animation a random animation and this
one's a rotate Z of 0 degrees to 308
degrees so kind of up here you can see
that it start at the end and that's just
iterating infinitely and I can start to
add other things like a skew or a
different view or rotate X in a third
dimension translate and just keep adding
different animations and now these are
all just adding to each other I've now
got a list of how fast the 20 animations
on the same property of transform and
they're all just working independently
and being able to adapt as we go and you
can even pause different ones and we get
a lot of options for smoothness which is
exciting and there's this concept of
bending animations so again I was
talking about how animation by default
attorney especially if you're just
talking about a start in an in-state
you're talking about linear motion so if
I click on a screen I can go to a
different place and it just goes in a
straight line but now base
the actions that I'm taking I can click
in multiple places and it kind of a
circular animation that's it's the
animations being bent on the fly based
on where I'm clicking whereas in the
past this would be very much a okay I'm
animating too here oh they clip
somewhere else okay well now I just got
to go in a straight line there but
because we're adding different
functionality adding different
transforms on the fly they just kind of
bend in the way that they're going into
a nice smooth curve so there's a lot of
possibilities in this realm so it's
gonna be exciting to see these be
promoted up to the old browsers and then
we've got a couple more here where we've
been talking about the JavaScript side
but it's also going to be available to
CSS so we through that document dot get
animations that's coming you're not
going to be able to just get the
JavaScript animations you started you're
gonna be able to get the CSS animations
the CSS transitions and then after that
the SVG animations and they'll all be
returned you'll be able to tell which
ones are CSS which ones came from
JavaScript if you need to do that so
that means that all the things would
play back rate and all the things that
aren't available in CSS today you
actually will have access to on your
image so if you want to keep doing CSS
animations that's great you are still
going to get a little bit more power
through the what's available in the web
animations API so here's a here's
another one where this is a C these are
CSS animated elements flying through
space and again now I have my playback
rate which all I'm doing here is I'm
taking a CSS animation that's defined in
one way and changing the playback rate
here at the bottom to go a little slower
to CSS animation but I get to have that
extra power through what JavaScript
provides there's Houdini which if you
haven't heard about Houdini is one of
those things that's kind of a mix
between CSS and JavaScript and that a
lot of is implemented through JavaScript
to augment what's available in CSS
and this gives us a lot more powers to
animate in CSS specifically CSS
variables so you can individualize your
animations in kind of new ways i've
demos for that one as well but that
one's more of the you should you should
look into it if you're if you haven't
already and then there's a few more
things like you can change the keyframes
in the middle of an animation you can
group and sequence them through like
specific ways that's coming in the next
level of the specification and there's
even timelines that aren't related to
time what does that even mean it means
like scrolling so you can scroll through
something and it'll animate based on the
scroll time or not the time but as you
scroll that's you're moving through your
timeline so so we've talked kind of
about the overall what's possible with
the web animations API in my usage a lot
of it comes through like why would I use
web animations API over CSS I think it's
it's good for randomized values you're
already kind of doing that in JavaScript
so just kind of keep everything in there
if you're modifying keyframes so I've
done work in the past where they needed
like some specific Springs and taking in
the functions of what are all the things
that Springs tension and those sciency
things and boiling down two functions
generating keyframes on that my first
iteration like generated a bunch of CSS
keyframes and then pushed that but with
the way I'm animations API just take
those values that those functions return
and kick off an animation directly and
in the in the API if you're already
using CSS animation and you're toggling
a lot of classes today then maybe you
just do it in in JavaScript if you're
needing to sequence things especially
more than a few things like would that
sing-along that's a lot of things to tie
together if you want to make sure that
they stay consistent and changing one
value doesn't break all the other ones
javascript might be a better way and if
you're already integrating with J's
frameworks like they often have hooks
into different things like the different
transition of Bentsen view and and other
things in react you know you're already
there this is also available too so you
know we've talked a lot and so have we
finally done it have we given everything
we need for animation and I think we all
know the answer is there's no like this
is very foundational stuff in we had
awesome stuff with JavaScript letting us
move things back in the day and we had a
lot of power with CSS to make things a
little bit more performance-based and
declarative and now we've got a few more
powers built on top of that hopefully
this means that libraries like green
sock can continue to innovate and push
further a lot of the things that have
landed in here came from libraries like
then just like we have document that
query selector because of jQuery as
these other libraries build things they
get funneled back down to the browser
and that's good because that allows them
that frees them up to do more and that
gives more power to individual users to
choose whether they want to use
libraries or do things in j/s or CSS or
SVG and do it in a way that's more
consistent than has been in the past so
if you want to know more
there's Indian of course ended up
originally by the efforts of Rachel
neighbors
there's the slack animation at work
slack group which is a lot of fun and
has a lot of people who work on the web
animations API spec so they're always
available to ask questions when things
are coming and really a great resource
their UI animation newsletter from
Barrelhead you know we didn't talk about
the why I think Val is one of those
people who can really like hit the point
home as to like why to animate and then
there's several episodes of shop talk
show especially like early on in the web
animations days these episodes were in
there and there's articles that
that you can search for and they were
little early but thank you very much
cope in Twitter I think we have a couple
minutes so I will go ahead and open the
floor up to question or two if there are
any
and there's also it's also fine if not
they will it'll be multiple so the
question was with the that composite
thing where I'm at your know adding
different pieces of a transform on top
of each other like what's really
happening there it's it's really if
there's five scales in there then all
the scales are gonna be applied the fun
thing about the transform is that like
it's all follows down to linear algebra
and matrix multiplication and all that
fun stuff and each one does it so like
the very first one you have in the list
it changes the coordinate system so if
you scale it then everything after
that's going to be at that scale and
then if you scale again then you just
kind of confounded that and if you had
the rotation then everything after
that's gonna also have that rotation and
yeah so it's if you have 30 scales in a
row it'll do whatever that map ends up
being yeah
well thank you again and enjoy the rest
of your day here at Thunder Plains